اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
احتجاجات وايران في يوم هالمئه النظام
يصعد بالاعتقالات والاعدامات وتحذيرات من
انفجار كبير
يمكن يصفوا قرار طالبان بحضر عمل النساء
بالمدمر ومسؤول امني في كابول للقاء
السلطات
11 قتيلا في اشتباكات القبليه في جنوب
دارفور والسلطات السودانيه تعلن حاله
الطوارئ
عاصفه ثلجيه ورياح قطبيه تجمد الحياه في
الولايات المتحده وبعض انحاء كندا عشيه
الميلاد
حياكم الله البدايه من ايران فبعدها مضيئه
يوم على اندلاع الاحتجاجات في ايران اعرب
الجمعيات المدرسيه حوزه قم العلميه عن
دعمها لتنفيذ احكام الصادره بحق الموقوفين
خلال المسير المسيرات المناهضه في وقت
اسفرت حمله القمه التي اطلقتها السلطات عن
مقتل 56 على الاقل بينهم 69 قاصرا وبلغ
عدد الاعتقالات اكثر من 18,000 متضاهر
طبعا ذلك وفقا لوكاله انه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه
يوجد طبيب ايراني الاعدام مشاهدينا وصفه
غضب شعبي كبير بسبب الاحكام المتعلقه
بالاحتجاج من القضاء الايراني وتنقل صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان قوات امن النظام الايراني
داهمت منزل الطبيب وزوجته واعتقلتهما
وضربتهما امام ابنتهم البالغه من العمر 14
عاما
حكم
[تصفيق]
طبعا فضلكم ذلك مشاهدينا استغاثه العائلات
الايرانيه مطالبه التواصل مع اطفالهم
المعتقلين والمعرضين لخطر الاعدام فيما
كشف تقرير استقصائي لشبكه سي ان ان
التعاون مع قناه 1500 تصوير الايرانيه عن
عائلات ايرانيه تطالب بانقاذ ابنائهم
المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام من بينهم امير نصر
ازاداني ومحمد مهدي كرامي وسمان ياسين
اه في المقابل وجه السياسي الاصلاحي
والنائب والسابق في البرلمان الايراني
حسين الانصاري راد رساله مفتوحه الى
المرشد الايراني حذر فيها من انفجار عظيم
اذا لم تحدث اصلاحات جذريه وخاطب انصارى
من ايقاع الى ان النظام صرح بان امريكا
واسرائيل وراء المظاهرات لكن الحقيقه ان
جميع الخبراء النزهاء يرددون منذ سنوات ان
هذا النوع من اداره الاقتصاد والثقافه
والسياسه سيؤدي الى كارثه ومن الاحتجاجات
في ايران الى ردود الفعل الدوليه حيث
اشاهدت لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي باستمرار اداره الرئيس
جوبيدا في محاسبه المسؤولين عن مواصفاته
بالعنف العشوائي ضد الاحتجاجات في ايران
وقالت في اللجنه عبر حسابها على تويتر
بقوه على تزايده الملاحقات القضائيه
وتنفيذ احكام الاعدام من جانب النظام
الايراني
تتحول الساحه في ايران من بقع مكتظه
بالمتظاهرين الى ميادين موت علنيا
بالرفعات هكذا يريدها النظام الايراني
ليخمد اصوات التظاهرات بحسب منظمه العفو
الدوليه التي وصفت هذا المشهد بالمحاكمه
الصوريه التي تهدف الى ترهيب المحتاجين
اعدم شخصان هذا الشهر محسن شكاري ومجيد
رضا رهن ورد وكلاهما لم يتجاوز عمره 23
ربيعا واعداد الاعدادات الوشيكه متضاربه
ما بين واحد و20 نسبه لبيانه العفو
الدوليه وثلاثه واربعين وفق شبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه وصولا الى 100 نقلا عن منظمه
حقوقيه لكن اسمين اخرين كانت المحكمه
العليا اعلنت انها قابلت حكم استئنافهما
معلله ذلك بقصور في تحقيقات محمد اقبادله
وسماء سيدي مين
لبس الخبر ساعات حتى تراجعت عن اقوالها
ووافقت على اعدام اقباله مضيفه ان
الاعتراض الذي ورد في ملفه مرفوض من قبل
المحكمه المعنيه التي قالت ان اقبادله
يواجه حكما بالاعدام بسبب مهاجمته افراد
الشرطه بسياره 100 يوم مضت ولم تخفت
التمديدات الغاضبه التي تصاحبها حمله
اعتقالات طالت مالا يقل عن 18,000 من
الغاضبين من النظام ورموزه اما القتله
فتجاوز عددهم ال 470 شخصا في حصيله غير
نهائيا اسراء الصغير العربيه
حول هذا الملف ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان
الايراني مسعود الفك اهلا بك معنا سيد
مسعود ما الذي يميز هذه الاحتجاجات عن
سابقها من الاحتجاجات في ايران
هذه الاحتجاجات
بلا شك كانت مختلفه مختلفه تماما من ناحيه
النوعيه والاستمراريه
واشعارات المطروحه
وتاثيرها الداخلي والخارجي مختلفه تماما
عن الاحتجاجات السابقه لماذا لان المشاركه
النسويه كانت لاول مره قد تفوق مشاركه
الرجال في الاحتجاجات وهذه تعتبر ظاهره
مهمه في التحول الاجتماعي في داخل ايران
وطبقه الشباب وفئه الشباب ايضا كان دورهم
مميزا
ومؤثرا في قياده الاحتجاجات هذه مساله
والمساله الاخرى عدم وجود قياده فوقيه
للاحتجاجات بل كانت الاحتجاجات في واقع
الامر قيادتها قياده افقيه داخل المجتمع
لا يمكن للسلطات القاء القبض على القائد
فاخماد الاحتجاجات بل يمكن القول بان
القياد
عام مشتركه في كل المدن الايرانيه بشكل
افقي هي التي تقود هذه الاحتجاجات وهناك
كثير من الامور لدراسه هذه الاحتجاجات
اللي التي اصبحت منحطه تاريخي في الاحتجاج
في ايران يحتاج الى دراسات طويله ام لهذا
الموسم
قال عنه انصاري انه سيؤدي الى كارثه ما هي
الكارثه التي يشير اليها
الكارثه هيئه اسقاط النظام لا توجد كارثه
اكثر من هذا الامر بالنسبه للذين يحتبرون
انفسهم ضمن النظام
ويقراون اجراس الانذار واجراس الحذر
لاصحاب القرار العليا الذين يتخذون
القرارات السياديه في ايران وهنا المرشد
الاعلى
والاقربون الى المرشد الاعلى الذين بيدهم
كل القرارات هذا في واقع الانذار لهم
الانقسامات بين داخل اعضاء النظام
الايراني كيف تقيم نسبه تاييدهم لما يقوم
به النظام تجاه المحتجين
في الوقت الحاضر
هناك نوعين من من المطالبات بالتعامل مع
المحتاجين نوع يدعو الى الاعدام
والى النفي وقطع
الارجل والايدي من خلاف كما دعت دعى بيان
مدرسين الحوجه العلميه او الحوزه الدينيه
وهم
مدرسون تابعون للنظام دعوا الى تنفيذ
الاحكام بهذه الطريقه واخرون الذين
يعتقدون تنفيذ احكام الاعدام والعنف
المفرد سوف يؤدي الى مجيد من الاحتجاجات
وقد يؤدي الاسقاط النظام
الايراني مسعود الفك
مشاهدينا في تسريحات سابقه خاصه بها قناه
العربيه اكد تيري ميوزى محامي الرهين
الفرنسيه في ايران سيسيل كولير بان
تواصلها لاول مره منذ احتجاز احتجازها مع
عائلتها تم تحت المراقبه وبان وضعها
النفسي كان صعبا للغايه
[موسيقى]
وبخصوص سماح السلطات الايرانيه للسفير
الفرنسيه بلقاء الراهين الفرنسيه سيسيل في
مكان احتجازها في الثالث والعشرين من
نوفمبر الماضي اكد المحامي بان اللقاء كان
تحت المراقبه الشديده ولم يكن هناك اي
احترام للخصوصيه فينوس
[موسيقى]
عبيد الليل
التابعه للامم المتحده في افغانستان رامز
الاكبر الذي سيلتقي سلطان الطالبان اليوم
حذر من ان قرار طالبان حضر عمل النساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه سيؤثر بشكل كبير
على عمليات الشؤون والاغاثه الانسانيه وان
الكثير من برامج الامم المتحده ستتاثر
فيما اكدت وكاله المعونه الدوليه افغان
عيد ان تعليق العمليات حدث على الفور
مشيره الى ان اكثر من نصف السكان يعتمد
على هذه المساعدات الانسانيه وفقا لوكاله
الاغاثه
حركه طالبان تواصل حملتها ضد النساء في
افغانستان لحرمانهن من التعليم والعمل
وزاره الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان خطبت
المنظمات غير الحكوميه الاجنبيه والمحليه
بتعليق توظيف النساء وهددت بالغاء رخص
العمل في حال عدم الامتثال لاوامر الحركه
على المنظمات الاهليه تعليقات توظيف
النساء وفي حال عدم الالتزام بالامر ستلغى
رخصه التشغيل الخاصه بالمنظمات
وفي محاوله لتبرير قرار الحركه في منع
توظيف النساء قالت وزاره الاقتصاد ان
الامر يعود لعدم التزامهن بالزي الذي
حددته طالبان
اوامر حركه طالبان الجديده اثار السجالات
ومخاوف من احتمال ان تسري على وكالات
الامم المتحده والمنظمات الانسانيه التي
لها وجود كبير في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اعلنت ايضا ان بعض الجامعات ستغلق لمده
اسبوع بسبب احتجاجات بعد الطلاب على منع
التعليم النساء مبرره الامر بعدم جاهزيه
تلك الجامعات وان كانت بعض مقاطع الفيديو
على مواقع التواصل قد اظهرت اطلاق النار
على الطلاب
قرارات حركه طالبان بمنع الطالبات من
الحضور الى الجامعات وعدم اكمال تعليمهن
اثار انتقادات دوليه حاده واحتجاجات ضد
اسرار طالبان على تهنئه دور المراه وتقويض
وجودها بالقوه جاسم محسن العربيه
الافغاني احمد سيد اهلا بك معنا سيد احمد
في استديوهاتنا في الرياض السلطات او
طالبان تحديدا الى ماذا تستند في قرارها
لمنع الطالبات من التعليم
من العمل في المنظمات
كثيره وجديه جاءت الى قياده طالبان حول
عمل المراه وتواجد المراه داخل
المحتسبين والرجال الامر بالمعروف وبعد
قادتهم او حتى الجنود يعني كان هناك شكاوى
وصرح بينا شكاوى
بانهن لا يراعين حتى القوانين همم التي
فرضتها الطالبان عليهم ولا القوانين
التشريعات الاسلاميه لذلك
هل هي مشروعه جدا
او اسره واحده حتى نتحدث عن حجاب
حجاب او عدم حجابي اختلاط عدم اختلاط هو
في النهايه وحريه لاي شخص يريد ان يتحدث
او يفعل ما يريد لكن طالبان تريد تقوم
بهذا العمل من ناحيه هي اصلا من ناحيه عدم
مراعاه الحجاب والاختلاط حسب وصفها ومن
ناحيه اخرى كذلك انها همم لديها قلق من
تواجد الفتيات الافغانيات في المنظمات
الاجنبيه تواجد الفتيات همم في المنظمات
هذه يعني تقارير اكثر معلومات اكثر لان
هذه المنظمات الاجنبيه حول ما يحصل داخل
افغانستان خصوصا اتجاه المراه من طالبان
لذلك لديها هذا اكبر من مجرد لباس الموضوع
[موسيقى]
كثير من المنظمات الدوليه للامم المتحده
تنشر في تقاريرها عن الاتحاد والعنف الذي
يحصل تجاه المراه وحتى يقصائها من المجتمع
والمؤسسه الحكوميه الان وصلنا الى
المؤسسات والمنظمات الدوليه من ناحيه اخرى
يعني هذا يسبب من مشكله داخل افغانستان
ويزيد من حالات الفقر في افغانستان يعني
كثير من الفتيات همم يعولون ويسرهن يعني
احنا في يابان السنه همم
دائما غالبا تجد في بعض الاسر همم الرجل
الاب الاخ الاخ الزوجه متوفى مقتول معاق
من سبب الحرب 40 عام يعني بذلك او الفتيات
يعلنون يسرون بعضهم بعضهم الاسره وكذلك
تعمل في تعمل وكذلك تدرس من الخروج
وكما تفضل لا يكون لديها محرم متوفر في
عائلاتها
يعني تريد باي طريقه ان تقتل المراه اذا
من يخدم همم هذه الاسره التي
طيب اا فضل ذلك سيد احمد ما الذي يمكن ان
يؤثر في قرارات طالبان هذه ربما امم
الطلاب المسؤولين المعلمين في الجامعات هل
يمكن اصواتهم ان تؤثر في قرارات طالبان
ربما
هذه اول بدايه التاثير كانت لو نعد الى
منع الدراسه منع الفتيات من التعليم
الجامعي في اول يوم او في خلال 24 ساعه من
صدور القرار 70 الاستاذ جامعي من كبار في
الجامعات افغانستان وخصوصا في جامعه
كابويرات
قدموا استقالاتهم اعتراضا وكذلك وجدنا منذ
ثلاثه ايام حتى الان همم الطلاب الجامعات
الكليات ليس الطلاب اقسام الطلاب الكليات
بشكل عام يرسلون الى ادارات الجامعاتهم
بانهم لن يحضروا الى المدائن الى الجامعات
والصفوف الدراسيه حتى همم العوده عن قرار
منع المراه لذلك يعني هي تسبب قال قوى اخر
شيئا طالبا يوم امس اصدرت باغلاق الجامعات
لمده اسبوع واحد في بعض ايات بسبب ما تحت
مبربنه غير مستعده هذه الجامعات تريد ان
تحدث اصلاحها داخلها هذا يظهر بانه الله
هناك طلبه يدرسون ولهنا كاسات اذا يحضرون
الى الصفوف الدراسيه كثيرون قدموا
استقالاتهم وجدنا عضو من الطالبان يوم امس
كان يتحدث في احد القنوات يطالب قياده
طالبان بان يمنع هؤلاء الاساتذه الذين
استقالوا من العوده الى التدريس لانه
وصفهم بانهم خونه في هذا الوقت شكرا لك
الانضمامك معنا في الاستديو الصحفي
الافغاني احمد سيد
مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل فرنسا تعلنون نقل
المتهم بقتل 3 اكراد الى مصحه النفسيه
احييكم من جديد اعلنت اجهزه الطوارئ في
اوكرانيا ان ثلاثه من افرادها لقو حذفهم
بالامس عندما انفجر لغم اثناء قيامهم
بازاله الالغام من اجزاء من منطقه خرسون
في رساله مسائيه عشيه عيد الميلاد وجهها
الرئيس
للشعب الاوكراني تعاهد فيها باعاده الحريه
لبلاده وقال ان الطائرات المسيره
والاختباء في الملاج لا يخيف الاوكرانيين
وان الطريق الى الحريه له ثمن كبير كما
وجدد الرئيس الاوكراني لاتهامه لروسيا
بالمسؤوليه عن قتل الافرانيين وتشريد
الملايين باستخدام المسيارات والصواريخ
اوكرانيا مشاهدينا تحولت بسبب الحرب الى
حقل تجارب للاسلحه وتقنيات القتال الحديثه
طرفاء الحرب يستخدمون ما توفر من
تراسناتهم لتحقيق التفوق على الخاص
في اخر خطابته
العسكريه الروسيه على ده طلع الانتاج
مطالبا للمجمع الصناعي العسكري للاستفاده
من الخبرات المكتسبه من الحرب لتطوير
ترسانه موسكو
الصفه الابرز في الحرب القائمه في
اوكرانيا هي الاعتماد على الطائرات
المسيره كالكلاشنكوف روسيه روسيا كذلك
لجات الى التصنيع الايراني الرخيص للحصول
على المسيرات المفخخه لضرب البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه
[تصفيق]
اكثر تطورا تستخدمها ضد اهداف مهمه كما
قرر القياده والسيطره ومخازن السلاح
الاوكرانيه كالصواريخ المجنحه كاليبر التي
يتراوح مداها بين 10500
و2500 كلم اما اوكرانيا فاعتمدت على سياره
بيرقدار التركيه في بدايه الحرب ثم توالت
عليها المساعدات من حلفائها الغربيين
فحصلت على سويتش بليد
مع زيارته
ستدخل منظومه الدفاع الجوي باتريوت لساحه
المعركه في اوكرانيا
السلطات المواليه لروسيا بدات في مدينه
ماريبول بهدم مسرح قالت اوكرانيا ان القوه
الروسيه قصفته في السادسه عشر من مارس
الصور التي التقطتها شركه ماكسار للاقمار
الصناعيه تظهر مدى الضرر الذي اصاب المسرح
قبل هدمه
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا قربت السلطات مشاهدينا رفع قرار
احتجاز المشتبه به بقتلي بثلاثه اكراد في
باريس لاسباب الصحيه وتم نقله الى مركز
للعلاج النفسي تابع للشرطه و قالت نيابه
العامه في باريس ان الطبيب الذي فحص
المجتبه به خلص الى ان الوضع الصحي للشخص
المعني لا يتوافق مع اجراء الاحتجاز
واضافت ان المشتبه به سيعرض او سيعرض على
قاضي التحقيق يعرض عندما تسمح حالته
الصحيه بذلك مؤكده ان التحقيقات ما زالت
مستمره وكانت العاصمه الفرنسيه قد شهد
اشتباكات عنيفه مشاهدينا بيننا متظاهدين
اكراد وبين الشرطه او قاعات واحده و30
جريحا في صفوف الشرطه وتسببت باعتقال احد
عشر محتجا التظاهرات اندلعت عقبه هجومنا
فرنسيه على مركز ثقافيه كردي في الدائره
العاشره ما تسبب بمقتل ثلاثه نشطاء اكراد
ونتابع ايضا مع الزميل فهد الدهوك كيف
كانت التظاهره صباح اليوم
ده الامور خرجت عن السيطره هناك فوضى
عالمه الان في شوارع العاصمه باريسنا
بالقرب على بعد امتار من ساحه الجمهوريه
تعزيزات امنيه من كل صوب الان تاتي هنا
على يمينه كما ترون الشرطه تحاول تفريق
المتظاهرين المتظاهرون يردون عليها برشقها
بالحجاره والمقذوفات
ايضا يقومون بعمليات احراق كما ترون هنا
قاموا بقلب سيارات وباحرقها
التظاهره بالدرجه الاولى جاءت بدعوه من
امام المركز الثقافي الكردي احمد كايا
الذي تعرض
للهجوم وكانت تابينا للضحايا وتكريما لهم
وايضا اا رفضا لي الروايه الفرنسيه التي
في مازال تقول ان القاتل الذي نفذ هذه
العمليه قام
بتنفيذها من تلقاء نفسه لذا هم يرفضون هذه
الروايه الفرنسيه ويقولون ان تركيا لها
ارتباطات بهذه العمليه
ويستدلون على ذلك من طبيعه المكان الذي
استهدف بانه استهدف ايضا في عام 2013
اغتيلات فيه ثلاث ناشطات كرديات همم
ويقولون ان هذه العمليه مشابهه لما حدث
عام 2013 والشرطه الفرنسيه لم تكن همم
تحمي هذا المركز يحملون الشرطه الفرنسيه
سياسيه وفنيه كثيره جدا بالاكراد وكل
الاشخاص الثلاثه الذين قتلوا وهم نجاء همم
يعرفهم او ي- ياتون الى المركز باستمرار
احدى هؤلاء كانت سيده هي كانت مقاتله
سابقه ضد تنظيم داعش في شمال سوريا نقلت
الى فرنسا للعلاج بعد اصابتها هناك خلال
المعارك انتهى يوم عصيب في العاصمه
الفرنسيه وبدات الان تتضح حجم الخسائر قوى
الاطفاء الان تحاول اطفاء بعض الحرائق
التي ما زالت مشتعله في عدد من الشوارع
ساحه الجمهوريه خلت تماما الان من
المتظاهرين الذين تفرقوا في عدد من
الشوارع الفرعيه لكن قوات الامن والشرطه
الفرنسيه ما زالت منتشره في الشوارع تحسبا
لاحتمال تجدد الاشتباكات مع المحتجين هذه
دهوك العربيه باريس
من فرنسا الى السودان التي اكد فيها نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني محمد حمدان
دجله ان السلطه لن تتردد في الاعتراف باي
تقصير او تجاوز صاحبه اداء افراد او
جماعات من الشرطه خلال تنفيذ القانون في
ختام احتفالات عيد الشرطه ان لا كبير على
القانون و تشهد بذلك ساحات العداله للعديد
من المحاكمات واشار ايضا الى وجود اللجنه
من الاجهزه
التي صاحبت الثوره
لا نتردد في في الاحتراف باي تقصير او
تجاوز صاحب اعداء افراد او جماعات من
الشرطه خلال تنفيذ القانون فالقاعد عندنا
لا كبير على القانون واي تجاوز نقابله
بالحسم وتشهد بذلك ساحات العداله للعديد
من المحاكمات الى افراد من الشرطه او
القوات النظاميه الاخرى بسبب تجاوز
تجاوزهم للقانون ونشير الى ان هناك لجنه
من الاجهزه المختصه تعمل في التحري
والتحديد في جميع الجرائم التي صاحبت
الثوره وقد تم تقديم عدد من البلاغات
للمحاكم ويجري التحري في بلاغات اخرى
تحقيقا لمبدا العداله وزياده حكم القانون
افادت صحيفه السودان شوبيون باعلن حاله
الطوارئ في ولايه جنوب دارفور بعد هجوم
المسلح على عده قرى اسفر عن سقوط قتلى
ومصابين وقالت الصحيفه ان حكومه جنوب
دارفور فوضت الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه
باتخابي كافه التدابير لحسم وما وصفته
بالانفلات الامني
في لبنان سلما حزب الله اللبناني خلال
الساعات الماضيه مطلق مطلق النار على
الدوريه الايرلنديه الى مخابرات الجيش
اللبناني بحسب مصادر مطلعه للشرق الاوسط
المصادر اكدت ايضا
مشاهد رفع مستوى التنسيق بين الجيش
اللبناني والقوات الدوليه مشيره الى ان
قوات يونسال طلبت منذ اللحظه الاولى لوقوع
الحادث باجراء تحقيق شفاف وبتوقف مطلق
النار وتقديمهم للعداله مديريه الصحه في
مناطق المعارضه بشمال غربي سوريا مشاهدينا
حذرت من عواقب كارثيه وتبيعات توقف
المنشات الطبيه والمراكز الصحيه في حال
عدم تجديد قرار ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
الاميه عبر الحدود من تركيا كما اطلقت
منظمات انسانيه محليه ودوليه تحضيرات
مشابهه وذلك بشان اللاجئين في شمال غرب
سوريا حيث يتساقم الوضع الانسانيه
نشير الى هذا العاجل مشاهدينا الى اضراب
عام يشمل المتاجر في مدينه بركان الكرديه
في ايران احياء لذكرى قتل الاحتجاجات
الى سياق نشرتنا والعيش في الشمال السوريه
ازدادوا صعوبه خاصه للفقراء الذين يكابدون
درجات الحراره المنخفضه وارتفاع اسعار
الخبز الناتج عن قله المخصصات من دقيق
القمح
السوري يقابله ارتفاع في اسعار الخبز
ليفاقم ظروف العيش الصعبه في منطقه
القامشليات من اعمار مختلفه ينتظرنا
لساعات للحصول على بعض الخبز باسعار
مناسبه
وما نقدر نشتري ربطات خبز وتنام عرسان
رغم الظروف القاسيه الا ان ملامح
الانسانيه ما زالت موجوده تطوع هذا الرجل
السبعيني لتسجيل اسماء الباحثين عن لقمه
الخبز حتى لا يضطر الى المبيت في الشارع
واحد وراء واحد ويروحون العالم كلها تفضل
من الشالات
الصبح يجي واحد اسمه محمود ياخذ هذا ويصيح
الواحد
الافران الشعبيه في القامشلي لا تتجاوز 15
فرنا
ومخصصاتها من دقيق القمح لا تتجاوز الطن
الواحد في حين ان حاجيات السكان تتجاوز
ثلاثه اطنان لكل فرن في ظل الاقبال الشديد
من اصحاب الدخل المحدود
[موسيقى]
اوضاع صعبه يعيشها الفقراء في الشمال
السوري في ظل المناشدات بتوفير كميات اكبر
من الدقيق للمخابز انس نماسي العربيه
عن فرصه اخيره لخريطه طريق في ليبيا
الساخنه جدا
يصف قرار طالبان بحضر عمل نسائي بالمدمر
ومسؤول اممي في كابول للقاء السلطات
احتجاجات وايران تدخل اليوم المئه والنظام
يصعد بالاعتقالات والاعدامات وتحذيرات من
انفجار كبير
11 قتيلا في اشتباكات قبليه في جنوب
دارفور والسلطات السودانيه تعلن حاله
الطوارئ
عاصفه ثلجيه ورياح قطبيه تجمد الحياه في
الولايات المتحده وبعض انحاء كندا عشيه
الميلاد
حياكم الله من جديد دعا قائد الجيش الوطني
الليبي خليفه حفتر من اسماها بالاطراف
المتصارعه في بلاده دعاهم لوضع خارطه
الطريق قابله للتطبيق تهدف هذه الخريطه
لتحديد موعد للانتخابات العامه حفتر وخلال
كلمه له مشاهدينا في بنغازي ووصف دعوته
بالفرصه الاخيره لتحقيق طموحات الشعب
الليبي
القياده العامه للجيش الوطني الليبي تمنح
الاطراف المتسارعه الفرصه الاخيره لوضع
خريطه طريق قابله للتطبيقه
ومحدده
في نهايه المطاف الى تحديد موعد الحقيقه
لاجراء الانتخابات العامه
يحتكم فيها البيبيون الى صناديق الاقتراع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ونحمل هذه الاطراف
كامل المسؤوليه في حالي عدد من جديد عن
تحقيق مطالب ورغباتي واعمال الشعب الليبي
يبقى في ليبيا حيث اكد قائد الجيش الليبي
خليفه حفتر ان القوات المسلحه هي اول من
نادى لاجراء انتخابات الحره ونزيهه داعيا
البعث الامميه لدى ليبيا لتحمل مسؤولياتها
لحل الازمه في البلاد
الى اجراءات الانتخابات نزيهه وشفافه
تنتجوا تنتج سلطات تكتسب شرعيتها من الشعب
مباشره دواء ولم نترك بابا للسلام الا
وطرقنا
وهنا بعثه الامم المتحده
تحمل مسؤوليتها
وواجباتها لحل الازمه الليبيه
اللازمه
للتوصل الى حلول الفعليه للقضيه
[موسيقى]
ننتقل بكم الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميل
ناصر اليك
مشاهدينا الكرام تحديث لارقام التداولات
في جلسه هذا اليوم ولكن لنقل بدايه على
الانخفاضات التي تشدها البورصه في مصر
وذلك في اول ردت فعل للسوق الاسهم المصريه
بعد قيام البنك المركزي المصري ليله
الخميس برفع اكبر من المتوقع في نسب
الفائده بلغ 300 نقطه اساس فيما كانت
التوقعات تتراوح ما بين 100 الى 200 نقطه
اساس من الرفع انخفاض على الاي جي اكس 30
لمستويات ما دون ال 14250 نقطه انخفاض
بواحد فاصل سبعه في المئه طبعا انخفاضات
على كل المؤشرات الرئيسيه الثلاث لن اعود
الان الى السوق السعوديه والتي تشهد بعض
الارتفاع الطفيف السوق تتحرك على مدار
الاسبوعين الماضيين بعد انخفاضها خلال
الجلسه دون ال 10,000 نقطه تتحرك في نطاق
عربي ضيق ما بين 10 الاف الى ال 10000
و300 نقطه ولم تسعف السحر حقيقه المكاسب
التي شاهدناها في سوق النفط يوم الجمعه
بمكاسب فقط الثلاثه ونصف النقطه المئويه
بنهايه الجلسه على خام براند هذا لم يسعف
السوق السعوديه في جلسه اليوم ويبدو بان
السقسه تستمر في هذا النطاق العربي حتى
نهايه السنه الاسهم التي نراقبها بوبا
العربيه طبعا اعاده احتساب السهم بعد
زياده راس المال عن طريق اسهم منحه اقوى
باور توقيع عقد شراء طاقه في اوزباكستان
لثلاثه مشاريع لطاقه الرياح بقدره واحد
ونصف جيجاوات كير عقد ب 30 مليون ريال مع
وزاره الداخليه سينومي سنتريس بيع قطعه
ارض في حي الرائد بالرياض بقيمه 700 مليون
ريال الارباح الدفتريه ستكون اقل او
الراسماليه ستكون اقل من 300 مليون ريال
والبنك الاستثمار يعلن عن توزيعات عن
النصف الثاني بوقع 45
هلله هذه لائحه الاسهم الاكثر تداولا في
هذه اللحظات ما زالت قيم التداول دون ال
900 مليون ريال حتى هذه اللحظه هذه اذا
المشاهدين كانت وقفتنا مع جلسه التداول
السعوديه نعد الان من جديد الى
الاستوديوهاتنا في الرياض والى زميله
فاطمه شكرا ناصر
نعود الى الاشتباكات في جنوب دارفور في
السودان وحول ذلك نظم الينا من الخرطوم
مراسل العربيه محمد عثمان اهلا بك معنا
محمد ما اخر المستجدات حول هذه الاشتباكات
نعم اهلا بك فاطمه ولايه جنوب دارفور تعيش
على واقعه اغتال قبلي عنيف جدا في هذه
الولايه منذ يوم الاربعاء الماضي اخر
الاخبار الوارده من ولايه جنوب دارفور
اعلان حاله الطوارئ في محليه بليل هذه
المحليه التي تبعد حوالي 17 كيلو متر من
حضره هذه الولايه مدينه نيالا امتدت رقعه
الاغتسال القبلي الى المنطقه الشماليه
والى الجزء الشمالي من مدينه نياله الى
قرى تبعد حوالي 15 كلم من مدينه االا احتج
المواطنون من تلك المناطق امام مقر امانه
الحكومه بولايه جنوب دارفور مطالبين
السلطات هناك بضروره حسم هذه التفلتات
القبليه ووقف نزيف الدم الذي سال فيه تلك
المنطقه بطبيعه على لجنه امن الولايه هي
في حاله انعقاد دائم وذلك للسيطره على
الموقف في ولايه جنوب دارفور وبالتحديد في
الجزء الشرقي والشمالي من هذه الولايه
علمنا ايضا من مصادر قبل قليل ان هنالك
حركه نزوح كبيره جدا من الجزء الشمالي
والجزء الشرقي الى مدينه نياله فتحت
المدارس لاستقبال النازحين والفرين من هذه
الاشتباكات العنيفه التي اندلعت منذ ثلاثه
ايام في ولايه جنوب دارفور شكرا لكم
وذلك اثناء مباراه بين الاهلي والاتحاد في
كاس السوبر لكره السله للرجال وقال
للمتحدث باسم الوزاره حسام عبد الغفار في
بيان الحصر المبدايه للحادث يشير الى ان
الاصابات بين كسور ونزيف مضيفا ان معظمها
لا تهدد الحياه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شهدت اغلب المحافظات العراقيه تساقط كميات
كبيره من الامطار تسببت في غرق احياء
العاصمه بغداد ومدن وبلدات اخرى وشنت حركه
المرور في طرقتها
للمره الثانيه على التوالي وفي غضون شهرين
فقط يتسببوه سقوطه مياه الامطار بكميات
كبيره بغرق اغلب احيائي وشوارع العاصمه
بغداد الامر الذي ادى الى شلل شبهتا من
للحركه فيها 19
الذي استمر اكثر من اثني عشر ساعه تسبب
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وسقوطها عميله
الكهرباء والاشجار في الطرقات الامر الذي
ادى الى تعطي للدوامي في الجامعات
والمعاهد والله من البارحه علاج
الماء يعني احنا اليوم ما قدرنا نطلع
للشغل
غرقه وتاذى بلكه الله الدوله يعني الدير
بالهم عليهم تعوضهم تعطيهم شيء يعني خطيه
طلعوا من بيوتهم رغم السنفار يا مانك
بغداد لكافه كوادرها الفنيه الا انها لم
تتمكن الى الان من سحب مياه الامطار من
احياء بغداد لتستعين باليات وزارتي
الدفاعي والداخليه التي تعمل منذ ساعات
للمساهمه في تصريف مياه الامطار التي سقطت
بكميات كبيره والتي تحولت الى سيول في
المدن والبلدات الحدوديه مع ايران من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
بالتزامن مشاهدينا مع الاحتفالات باعياد
الميلاد وراس السنه تشهد مدينه بيت لحم
ووسط الضفه الغربيه ازدهار ملحوظا في قطاع
السياحه الاف السياح عادوا الى المدينه
بعد نحو عامين من الانقطاع اضراب تفشي جاء
رائحه كورونا
في ساحه كنيسه المهد مجموعه اوروبيه تتسوق
من محلات بيع التحف الشرقيه المنتشره في
الجوار شبان من امريكا يحتسون القهوه
العربيه في المقاهي لقد عادت رئه المدينه
لتتنفس عادت السياحه وعاد نبيل ينفض غبار
الركود عن بضاعته استعدادا لبيعها الحمد
لله
بيت لحم في حركه سياحيه بشكل يعني ملحوظ
طبعا ما رجعنا للحركه اللي كانت ما قبل
الجائحه طبعا بنتمنى هلال عيد الميلاد
اعياد الميلاد حاليا نتمنى حاليا انه يعني
تكون هاي السنه حركه اكثر مثل ما عم نسمع
انه ان شاء الله متراقبين حركه سياحيه الى
المدينه
بدايه العام نحو 600 الف ساعه ويتوقع ان
يستمر توافد الالاف خلال الاسابيع القادمه
نسبه الاشغال في الفنادق وصلت لنحو مئه في
المئه والمصلون من شتى بقاع الارض يدخلون
ويخرجون من كنيسه المهد احنا قطعنا فتره
عن العالم واليوم رجعنا لحتى نشوف سياحه
جايه من كل مكان في العالم لحتى يزوروا
مكان ميلاد السيد المسيح وطبعا خصوصا في
اعياد الميلاد المجيده وتسع مدينه بيت لحم
حاليا لفتح شركات وتوقيع اتفاقيات خارجيه
لاعاده السياحه لما كانت عليه قبل الجاهه
بحيث تستقطب المدينه سنويا زهاء مليونين
ونصف المليون زائر
الى مدينه بيت لحم يشغلون شوارعها
وفنادعها ويتسوقون من متاجها بتزامن مع
الاحتفالات باعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
كل ذلك يعيد للمدينه شيئا من رونقها الذي
فقدته خلال الاعوام القليله الماضيه من
مدينه بيت لحم عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اما الان وقفه سريعه مع ابرز احداث يونيو
لهذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ميكي
انا بقاء الكتله الصدريه
عائقا امام تشكيل الحكومه
وكل نواب الكتله زادهم الله شرفا
مستعدون للاستقاله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
60 يوم جنبي
[موسيقى]
في امريكا سجلت ليله عيد الميلاد سقوط
ثلوج كثيفه غطت المنازل والسيارات وشوارع
المدن في الولايه وادت عاصفه شتويه الى
تدني درجات الحراره بشكل غير مسبوق
[موسيقى]
وجنوب الولايات المتحده مشاهدينا يعاني
مئات المهاجرين المكسيكيين من البرد
القارس ودرجات الحراره المتدنيه والصقيع
وذلك بانتظار قرار امريكي يسمح لهم
بالدخول
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
بل يمكن يصف قرار طالبان بحضر عمل النساء
بالمدمر ومسؤول اممي في كابول للقاء
السلطات
احتجاجات في ايران تدخل اليوم المئه
والنظام يصعد بالاعتقالات والاعدامات
وتحذير لخمر من انفجار كبير
11 قتيلا في اشتباكات قبليه جنوب دارفور
والسلطات السودانيه تعلن حاله الطوارئ
عاصفه ثلجيه ورياح قطبيه تجمد الحياه في
الولايات المتحده وبعض انحاء كندا عشيه
الميلاد في امان الله
[موسيقى]